Well, how the heck do you get a job as the white house photographer?
It seems like there are so many photographers, uh, throughout the country,
um, and, uh, you know, photo journalism.
It's something that makes me really sad.
And I'd love to talk to you about this too, where I feel like as a field, um,
uh, it's shrinking, uh,
in large part because so many of these newspapers are folding in that, uh,
the newspapers would be the primary employment magazines to the print magazines.
Um, so before we get into kind of the future of photo journalism, how did you,
uh, develop, uh,
and then wind up with maybe the highest profile photo journalist gig in the
world?
Well, I mean, let me preface this by saying that given where we are today,
which is, um, you know, not long after Joe Biden has been elected.
I see a lot of people reaching out to me saying I want to be Joe Biden's
photographer. And, you know, in my response to them is I try to be blunt.
If, if Joe Biden doesn't know you now,
he's not going to hire you. You know? I mean,
there's these out of campaigns photographers in the last few years, you know,
that that's the guy that's likely to get the job for me. Uh, I just,
by sheer coincidence, these things happened in life.
I was working for the Chicago Tribune. I was based in DC and Washington.
So when Barack Obama was elected to the Senate in 2004, uh,
Jeff Zelena,
who was then a reporter with the Washington Bureau of the Tribune G and I
documented Obama's first year in the Senate,
and I got access that nobody else got,
because that was with their quote unquote hometown newspapers.
So I got to know him on a professional, uh, you know,
just in a professional way, but he also got a chance to see how I worked,
you know, which is, you know, I like to say I worked me, you know,
a small footprint and try not to interfere with what's going on. Um, and, and,
and, you know, and he saw that I took my job seriously. So, you know,
skip ahead to four years, he gets elected president and asked me to, you know,
to be as white house apart. So that's the way it happened for me.
I'd imagine there were campaign photographs being taken all the time. That was,
so that was not you, or that was you.
2007 Is when he started the campaign.
This was started actually in February of 2007, pretty, pretty early.
And I covered probably the first three months of the campaign. And then I quit.
I quit it's a trip Tribune because I thought they had just been bought by a real
estate magnet. And I didn't like the direction the newspaper was going.
I was, uh, you know, I,
I just didn't think that I could stomach it anymore.
And even though I sort of had the inside track to covering this campaign,
I just could not see myself working for the, the trip unit anymore.
And I ended up taking a, uh,
a teaching job photojournalism teaching job at Ohio university.
Um, and then I would occasionally as a freelancer, uh,
hooked up with him on the campaign trail. Um,
so I sort of kept my foot in the door a little bit.
And then he wins in 2008. Uh, and then you get the word, Hey,
come back to DC and, uh, um,
become the white house photographer that must've been quite a call. Was it from,
uh, Barack himself or was it from someone on his team?
You know, Gibbs was, um,
kind of my main contact with Obama and, you know, and Robert Gibbs,
a lot of people, you know, just think of him as the press secretary,
but gives was one of the most influential Bates.
He was really like sort of a senior advisor, uh, as well as the press secretary.
So he w he was the one who called me on behalf of the president of legs.
He called me the night before classes for the winter quarter were,
we're supposed to begin and on a Sunday night. And so the following morning,
Monday,
I walked into my boss at Ohio university and told him that I was
leaving that afternoon for DC. I was quitting my job.
I kind of have given them a heads up, this might happen, but, you know,
you never know until, until you get that call. So.
And you proceeded to spend eight years as the white house
photographer. Uh, so I mean, obviously you had spent a lot of time in DC,
so you're very familiar with the environment. Um,
but coming into the white house, um,
that must have been an incredible journey where you
must've felt like you were documenting history essentially every day
for, uh, for eight years. Um,
what was that adjustment like? Um,
and the other question I'd have is it seems completely physically impossible to
me for any one human to cover everything that happened in the white house.
So this was that like a whole team of you.
Yeah, I had a staff, um, but my, my approach going in was,
um, that I was going to be all in to every day,
because my attitude was, if you were going to document for history,
you a, you can't predict when history is going to happen, you know,
you don't guess you don't always get noticed. Um,
but then also, uh, in terms of the target fee, you know,
I know the fleeting moments, little moments,
the way he interacts with certain people, uh,
if you're not there all the time, you're,
you're definitely not going to make that picture.
And so I wanted to make sure that I was all there all the time to
make those fleeing moments, cause I didn't ever want to miss any.
So now sort of the way I approached, uh, the job and I, I,
you know, I knew what I was in for. Uh, I don't think my wife knew with us,
um, because you know, you kind of put your personal life on hold for, you know,
in my case for eight years. But, um, you know, I,
I did have a staff,
so don't feel sorry for me because I could have easily
taken a day off here and there. But, uh, you know,
my attitude was just always be there.
So when does the day start and end for you in that situation? Like,
I feel like you'd want to live near the white house just to be able to get
there.
I didn't live that far 15, 20 minutes away.
And, um, I would try to get there, you know,
one of the things that we have to worry about is staffers that he,
he doesn't really have to worry about his, you know, you gotta commute,
you gotta get there. Whereas his commute was, you know,
two minutes walk residents too. So,
but I will try to get there at least an hour before him. Uh, he would,
he would come down to the oval office sometime between nine and 10 in the
morning. Uh, so I tried to get there, you know,
about an hour before I did have responsibilities as the head of my office.
And I would try to deal with those either early in the morning or at the end of
the day. And then I would basically tag along with him, um,
all day long until he went home for dinner. And, um, you know,
and sometimes after dinner he would come back to the West wing or there'd be,
um, events, uh, you know,
on the state floor or outside of DC that he would go to at night.
And so, you know, every day was a little different,
but pretty much I would just tag along with him, you know,
at least 10 hours a day, sometimes 15, sometimes longer.
So you you're documenting him. People like me come in and people like me,
you don't really remember. Cause, uh, I met president Obama, uh,
let's say three or four times, something like that. Um,
either in a group or in a collective setting and you were joking that like by
the six picture, you might recognize someone again.
Um, I did get a picture every time I met him, which was kind of nice. It's like,
it's just, you're around him. They're all,
there were always these photographers trying to capture the moment. Um, so,
and you don't even realize it when you're the guest at that moment.
And so then you just get the photo later and you're like incredible, um,
all the bike stages, uh, immortalized. Um, now, uh, you,
you probably have all sorts of, um, crazy experiences and recollections.
Was there anything that you're able to share about an experience where you were
like, wow, that just happened for me.
A lot of the,
the wild moments were not necessarily like the
big event, but more, um, the, the,
those moments that I talked about, those little moments, which really, um,
define him as a human being, you know, I mean, I just,
this is just a for instance, I mean, Ben Rhodes, um, who, you know,
was a deputy national security advisor and his daughter,
he CA he came in with his daughter like around Halloween time one year,
and she was just learning to crawl.
And so Obama gets down on the rug of the oval
office, squats down and gets Ella to, to crawl to him.
And then he lies down on his back and he's lifting her up. And, you know,
those moments are just like,
I can't believe this is happening as I'm photographing this. Um, you know,
certainly the bin Laden raid and big historic events
like that obviously are also wow.
And a kind of different way where you sort of really feel the weight
of history, uh, taking place right in front of you. Um,
so, um, but you know, I mean,
it's like one of the things that was advantageous about being a seasoned
photographer photojournalist is I was sort of able
to, to keep my emotions in check, you know,
and not get so, um, high, if you will,
when, when these, uh, when these big moments are happening. So, you know,
just sort of trying to keep my level pretty even.
So I'm not so overwhelmed by what's happening, that I'm still able to make,
you know.
Thank you for listening in. I hope you enjoyed this conversation. If you did,
please do subscribe to yang,
speaks and click on notifications so we can let you know,
every time we have a new episode.